so what do you think about Andrew Tate I
think his views are horrendous I'm glad
that he's off social media and that he's
been banned on most platforms what are
one of the views that you disagree with
what he thinks about women that women
are his property like women have to do
whatever their husband says like that's
a big no no for me he helps men fight
depression that's actually one of his
biggest viewed YouTube videos what are
your thoughts on this how does he do
that I've never seen that video he just
talks about leaving the Matrix taking
personal responsibility going to the gym
just self-improvement what do you think
about that from what it sounds like he's
telling men that they have to fight
through their feelings and I feel like
that's not the right to approach things
I think men are supposed to be
vulnerable and should be vulnerable and
can be emotional any kind of like toxic
masculinity where you're telling men to
fight through all of that is not okay in
my back can you define toxic masculinity
yeah toxic masculinity
um to me it's basically you know
um this belief that uh